ايه ده المشاهدين وحسب ما ذكرت صحيفه
جورنال فان النظام الايراني يوظفو للالاف
من الموالينا لقمع المحتجين لكن من هم
هؤلاء المؤيدين له كيف يحافظوا النظام على
اخلاصهم وفقا للصحيفه الامريكيه فان هؤلاء
العناصر يشكلون الحارس الثوري بالاضافه
الى حزب الله الايراني والمليشيات الاخرى
الاقل رسميا ومعظمهم من خلفيات متواضعه
اقتصاديا ومحافظه اجتماعيا للحفاظ على
الوضع الراهن تستدرجوا وتغري طهران هؤلاء
الناس من خلال الامتيازات والوظائف
والاسلحه من جانبه قال الباحث الايراني
بجامعه تنسى سعيد جوكار قال ان عمليات جمع
الموالين تبدا من سن المبكر وذلك في
معسكرات الاطفال
ونوادر الاحياء فئران تهيئوا شباب من
عائلات المحافظه للانضمام الى البسيج تقوم
بتدريبهم على المبادئ الدينيه وموجات
الحكومه المعديه للغرب الباحث اضعف ان
الشباب المولين يحضن بالاولويه في افضل
الجامعات الايرانيه مما يضعهم في صف
المناصب الحكوميه العليا